can you still man the case
of Greta
uh who's a representative of alarmism
that we need that kind of level of
alarmism for people to pay attention and
to think about climate change so you
said this singular View
uh
is is not the correct way to look at
climate change just the emissions
but for us to have a discussion
shouldn't there be somebody who's uh
really raising the concern can you still
in the case of for alarmism essentially
or is there a better term than alarmism
uh
commit communication of like holy [ __ ]
we should be thinking about this so I I
think you know I I totally understand
why credit tunberg is doing what she's
doing I I have great respect for her
because if you know I I look at a lot of
kids growing up and they're basically
being told you're not going to reach
adulthood or at least not you're not
going to get very far into adulthood uh
and that of course you know this the
media are hurtling towards Earth and
then this is the only thing we should be
focusing on I understand why she's
making that argument I I think it's at
the end of the day it's incorrect and
I'm sure we'll get around to talking
about that and one of the things is of
course that her whole generation uh you
know I can understand why they're saying
you know if if we're going to be dead in
12 years why would I want to study that
you know why would I really care about
anything so so I totally want to sort of
pull Greta and many others out of this
uh end of the world fear but I totally
get why she's doing it I think she's
done on a service in the sense that
she's gotten more people to talk about
climate and that's good because we need
to have this discussion uh I think it's
unfortunate and this is just what
happens in almost all policy discussions
that they end up being you know sort of
discussions from from the extreme groups
because it's just more fun on media uh
to to have sort of the the total deniers
and the and the the people who say we're
going to die tomorrow and it sort of
becomes that discussion that's more you
know it's more sort of a mutt wrestling
fight so what do you think the modern
wrestling fight is not useful or is
useful for communication for Effective
science communication on one of the
platforms that you're a fan of which is
Twitter
yeah I wrote a piece recently on my
sustain what column saying if you go in
there
for the entertainment value of seeing
those knock down fights I guess that's
useful if that's what you're looking for
the thing I found Twitter invaluable for
but it's a practice
it's just like the workouts you do or
you know
it's how do I put this tool to use today
thinking about energy sufficient energy
action in poor communities how do I put
this tool today learning about what
really happened with Ian the hurricane
you know who was most at risk and how
would you build back build forward
better I hit build back or you can go
there and just watch it as an
entertainment value that's not going to
get the world anywhere you don't think
entertainment I I wouldn't call it
entertainment but giving voice to the
extremes isn't a productive Way Forward
it seems to
you know to push back against the main
narrative it seems to work pretty well
in the American system we think politics
is totally broken but maybe that works
that like oscillation back and forth you
need a grata and you need somebody that
pushes back against the guard to get
everybody's
just to uh to get everybody's attention
the the fun of battle right over time
creates progress well and this gets to
the you know people who focus on
communication science I'm not a
scientist I write about this stuff
if you're going to try to prod someone
with a warning like yeah this is three
years apart nuclear winner nuclear
winner and I didn't talk about that
global warming well yeah we'll talk
about it but look at look at that you
know this is three years apart in the
covers of magazine yeah and uh but then
you have to say to what end if you're
not directing people to a basket of
things to do and if you're if you want
political change then it would be to you
know support a politician if you want
energy access it would be to look at
this 370 billion dollars the American
government just put into play on climate
and say well how can my community
benefit from that and and I've been told
over and over again by people in
government
jigar Shah who heads this giant Loan
program the energy Department he says
what I need now is like 19 500 people
who are worried about climate change
maybe because Greta got them worried
but here's the thing you could do you
can connect your local government right
now with these multi-million dollar
loans so you could have electric buses
instead of diesel buses
and that's an action pathway
so without so you know alarm for the
sake of getting attention or clicks
to me is not any more valuable than
watching a an action movie and and again
I think also it very easily ends up sort
of skewing our conversation about what
are the actual Solutions uh you know
because yes it's great to uh to get rid
of the diesel bus but probably not for
the reason people think it's because
diesel buses are really polluting in the
you know in the air pollution sense
right right that is why you should get
rid of them uh and again if you really
wanted to help people for instance with
hurricanes you should have better you
know uh rules and Zoning in in Florida
uh which is a very different outcome so
so the the mud wrestling fight also gets
our attention diverted towards solutions
that seem uh easy fun you know sort of
the electric car is a great example of
this the electric car has somehow become
almost the sign that I care and I'm
really going to do something about uh
climate of course electric cars are
great and they're probably part of the
solution and they will actually cut
carbon emissions somewhat but they are
incredibly ineffective way of cutting
carbon emissions right now uh they're
fairly expensive you have to subsidize
them a lot and they still emit quite a
bit of CO2 both because the batteries
get produced and because they you know
usually run off power that's not strong
you're in love with